amid tight security japan's prime
minister fumio kishida arrives for the
funeral of shinzo abe
other former leaders were also in
attendance at this private ceremony for
family and friends
but the assassination of japan's
longest-serving prime minister has
stunned many and some of the world's
most senior diplomats travelled to
deliver their condolences in person i
shared with the prime minister
letters to the abe family from
president biden and
we simply
want them to know
that
we deeply feel their loss
on a personal level as well
as the funeral ceremony was performed
inside zojiji temple large crowds queued
outside to lay floral tributes
there was a sense of security when he
was prime minister we felt safe with him
in charge of the country and i supported
him so this really is quite unfortunate
he was my favorite prime minister so i
came here to say goodbye
many others had come to do the same
thousands of people waiting quietly and
patiently to pay their final respects to
japan's former prime minister shinzo
air heavy with the scent of the floral
tributes they've brought
but also a sense of disbelief that a man
who loomed so large over japanese life
for more than a decade
is so suddenly and violently
gone as the ceremony concluded a hearse
containing abe's body turned onto the
streets
spontaneous applause and cries as
mourners bit him farewell
the funeral cortege passed the offices
of the liberal democratic party which he
led to three election victories and a
brief stop outside japan's diet the
parliament for lawmakers to pay their
respects
finally driving past the office of the
prime minister that he occupied longer
than any other
now leaving for the last time tony chang
al jazeera tokyo
tomi hiko taniguchi served as special
advisor and speechwriter for shinzo abe
he says the former prime minister was
held in high regard by japan's allies
mr abe
especially when
he came back in office the second time
after
recovering from his long illness of
ulcerative colitis
was very much a determined conviction
politician
determined to give
clearly defined goals
for japan's future
it's been extremely rewarding i have to
say
to work with such an individual
whose
compass moral compass
is very much
unshakable without japan's security bill
that shinzo abe spent so much amount of
his political capital
you couldn't build
an adequate amount of deterrence
as against
japan's neighbors
russia
north korea
china one should take into consideration
this country is faced with those three
undemocratic
nuclear powers australian prime minister
malcolm turnbull and scott morrison
both called shinzo abe visionary leader
and leader mentor shinzo abe has built
very good rapport not only with donald
trump but also three successive
presidents of the united states
two
uh prime ministers of india three prime
ministers of the uk
so
his
focused attentions on big picture sort
of issues has earned reputation
from among his g7 colleagues i'd have to
say